[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم انسي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى من رام الله تاتيل هذه
الصور في يوم دامن في الضفه الغربيه رصاص
الاحتلال قتل احد عشر فلسطينيا واصاب اكثر
من مئه في نابلس
وهذه الصور تاردنا من كياز قبل يومين من
الذكرى الاولى لبدء حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا القصف يتركز على خرسون في الجنوب
ودونيتسك وجبهه باخموت في الشرق
وفي ورسو اجتمع قاده ما تعرف بدول الجناح
الشرقي في النيتو بحضور الرئيس الامريكي
الذي دعا الى زياده الدعم المقدم
لاوكرانيا لمساعدتها في الدفاع عن سيادتها
وهذه الصور تلدنا من موسكو حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه ان مقاربه بلاده في مجال
استخدام السلاح النووي لن تتغير في اشاره
الى المخاوف من اللجوء للسلاح النووي
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تصعيد اسرائيلي دامن في الضفه الغربيه هو
الاعنف منذ سنوات قوات الاحتلال تقتل 10
فلسطينيين خلال اقتحام مدينه نابلس في
عمليه لافته في حجمها وعدد الجرحى يتجاوز
100 عرين الاسود تتوعد والقسام تحذر من
نفاذ صبر المقاومه والسلطه تطالب مجلس
الامن بحمايه دوليه للشعب الفلسطيني
بوتياريو يحذر من التداعيات وقلق امريكي
من ارتفاع مستوى العنف
اجتماع غير مسبوق لقاده الجناح الشرقي
للنيتو برئاسه بايدن بوتين يعتبر حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا دفاعا عن ما سماه
اراضيها التاريخيه ومع حديث عن مبادره
تسويه صينيه كيف تقول انها تقبل باي
اقتراحات دوليه للسلام شرط ان تكون وفق
شروطها
بعد تقارير عن تجاوزات في انشطه ايران
النوويه وفد من خبراء الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه في طهران ايران ترفض اي
ضغوط سياسيه بشان انشطتها النوويه تؤدي
الى التزامات من طرف واحد وتنفي اي محاوله
لتحصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه اكبر من 60%
ووزير خارجيتها يقول ان بلاده مستعده
لاتمام مباحثات فيينا
مع اتساع دائره الاعتقالات في تونس الحزب
الجمهوري يعلن توقيف امنه العام عصام
الشاب والامن يعتقل قياديه بارزه في جبهه
الخلاص المعارضه الاتحاد الاوروبي يعرب عن
قلقه حياله تطورات في تونس ويقول ان
البلاد بحاجه الى حلول لتحدياتها الحاليه
والمستقبليه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مقتل احد عشر فلسطينيا
واصابه اكثر من 100 برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي خلاله هجوم لها على نابلس
سرافقه مع اشتباك ومع حصار منزل بدعوى
اعتقال مطلوبين في البلده القديمه ووسط
المدينه وقال مسؤول المكتب الاعلامي في
حركه الجهاد الاسلامي التي استشهد قائد
كتيبه نابلس في سرايا القدس التابعه لها
قال ان المقاومه لن تفرط في حقها في الرد
على ما سماه العدوان الاسرائيلي الغاشم
على نابلس من جهتها حذرت كتائب القسام في
غزه من ان صبرها اخذ في النفاذ وانها
تراقب مسمتها جرائم العدو المتصاعده في
جهه الاهالي في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما
اهداف عمليه الاحتلال الواسعه النطاق في
نابلس اليوم وقد جاءت النتيجه على الاتي
29% قالوا ان الهدف هو تهيئه الاجواء
لتصعيد واسع يتجاوز الضفه وقال
38% ان عمليه نابلس تاتي في اطار التغطيه
على مشكلات اسرائيليه داخليه بينما وضعها
ثلاثه وثلاثون في المئه في سياق ارضاء
المتشددين الاسرائيليين
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعنا في الحصاد ايضا مع اكماله ثلاث
سنوات في السجون المصريه صحفي الجزيره
ينفذون وقفه احتجاجيه للافراج عن المنتج
في قناه الجزيره بهاء الدين ابراهيم وشبكه
الجزيره تدعو الى الافراج عنه وعن زميله
هشام عبد العزيز وربيع الشيخ
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
احد عشر فلسطينيا واصابه اكثر من 100
اخرين حالات بعضهم خطيره بالاضافه لاكثر
من 250 حاله اختناق بالغاز المسيل للدموع
خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مدينه نابلس الشماليه الضفه الغربيه وقد
اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال التي حاصرت
منزلا بذريعه اعتقال مطلوبين هذا واعلنت
سرايا القدس التابعه لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي استشهاد قائد كتيبه نابلس محمد
ابو بكر جنيدي خلال المواجهات
هذا البيت المتاكل في المدينه العتيقه في
نابلس كان هدف العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
قصفه الاحتلال بالصواريخ وفجر الجدران
والهدف قتل المقاومين حسام سليم ومحمد
جنيدي بعد ان رفضاه تسليما نفسيهما
وانفجارات زي صواريخ يعني بيوت قديمه عنا
احنا زي اللي هيك تفاجانا بعد ثلاث اربع
ساعات انه صوت انفجار مش مسترجين نطلع له
مستشهدين ناس بقلب البيت اللي جنبنا
قتل المقاومان بزعم انهما من قاده عرين
الاسود ونفذا هجمات ضد جنود ومستوطنين
وكان مع رفاقهما يخططان للمزيد
اما خارج ازقه البلده القديمه فاستخدم
الاحتلال الرصاص الحي
استهدف مقاومين ولم يكتفي بذلك
بل اطلق النار مباشره على مدنيين فقتله
مسنين ومنع الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول الى
الجرحى تحاول الحكومه الاسرائيليه كما
يبدو تصدير ازمتها الداخليه عبر الخوض
والدمج الفلسطيني والدفع باتجاه تصعيد قد
تنفلت اموره هذه ناحيه والناحيه الثانيه
ان الاعتبار الامني عند اسرائيل اهم من اي
اتفاقيات او تفاهمات حتى لو كانت
بوساطه دوليه
وفي خضم جنازه شارك فيها الالاف وتقدمها
مئات المقاومين اكدت عناصر مجموعات عرين
الاسود وكتيبه بلاطه انهم ماضون على درب
الشهداء في المقاومه
القياده الفلسطينيه اكدت انها ستتوجه
مجددا الى مجلس الامن الدولي خاصه بعد ان
ضربت الحكومه الاسرائيليه بعرض الحائط
التفاهمات السياسيه اما الاحتلال فرفع
درجه التاهب خاصه القبه الحديديه بعد
التهديدات التي اعلنتها فصائل المقاومه
كافه
هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون ما حدث فالاحتلال لم
يقتل مقاومين فقط بل استهدف مدنيين بينهم
مسنون عمليه تاتي برايي كثيرين ضمن محاوله
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تصديم ازمتها
الداخليه حتى وان سرع ذلك من الوصول الى
لحظه الانفجار الجزيره نابلس
قال وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن جزير انه
اوعز للمفتش العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه
بتعزيز قوات الشرطه في كافه انحاء اسرائيل
في اعقاب عمليه نابلس واشاد بن جزير في
تغريده بقوات جيش الاحتلال والقوات الخاصه
والشباك الذين قاموا بقتل من وصفهم
بالمخربين وقال ان اسرائيل ستستمر في
ملاحقه من يحاول المساس بها وستوجه لها
لهم ضربه ساحقه
ومنذ بدايه العام الحالي واصلت اسرائيل
التصعيد في الاراضي المحتله من خلال شن
عمليات متتاليه على مناطق عده في الضفه
الغربيه في هذا التقرير نتعرف على بعض هذه
العمليه
الحكومه الاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ اسرائيل
تكتب اولى رسائلها بدم الفلسطينيين في
الاراضي المحتله
منذ بدايه السنه اي خلال اقل من شهرين سقط
61 شهيدا فلسطينيا في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله بينهم ثلاثه عشر طفلا وامراه مسنه
شنت اسرائيل عمليات كثيره وتوغلت قواتها
في مناطق مختلفه من الضفه من هذه العمليات
استهداف بيت لحم في الثالث من يناير ما
ادى الى استشهاد طفل في مخيم دهيشن ارادت
قوات الاحتلال تنفيذ اعتقادات فقتلت الطفل
برصاصه في الصدر
بعد ذلك بيومين اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال مخيم
بلاطه شرقيا مدينه نابلس ما ادى الى
استشهاد ماهر ابو زيتون برصاصه في الراس
اطلقها جنود الاحتلال
[تصفيق]
في الخامس والعشرين من يناير اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال بلده عناتا في قضاء مدينه القدس
بهدف هدم منزل الشهيد عدي التميمي استشهد
خلال الاقتحام فتى فلسطيني واحتجزت قوات
الاحتلال ثمانيه فلسطينيين عشره ايام وفي
السادس والعشرين من يناير ارتكبت قوات
الاحتلال مجزره في جنين سقط عشره الشهداء
بعد ان دفعت قوات الاحتلال باعداد كبيره
من جنودها الى محيط مخيم جنين بهدف اعتقال
افراد خليه تنتمي لسرايا القدس
في السادس من فبراير اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مخيم عقبه جبر جنوب مدينه
اريحا سقط في هذه العمليه خمسه شهداء
بينهم منفذه عمليه في مستوطنه قريبه من
اريحا كما جرح ثلاثه فلسطينيين برصاص جنود
الاحتلال وفي الثاني والعشرين من فبراير
ارتكبت قوات الاحتلال مجزره اخرى في نابلس
سقط في هذه المجزره عشره شهداء واصيب اكثر
من 100 فلسطيني استمرت العمليه اكثر من
اربع ساعات ونصف اطلق خلالها مقاومون
فلسطينيون النار تجاه قوات الاحتلال
اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
قلق بلاده من ان يؤدي الهجوم على نابلس
الى تراجع جهود اعاده الاستقرار اضاف نادي
برايس ان الولايات المتحده قلقه من مستوى
العنف في الضفه الغربيه واسرائيل وانها
تحث الجانبين الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني على
وقف الاعمال التي تشعل التوتر وقد رحب
نادي برايس بالتفاهم الذي توصل اليه
الفلسطينيون واسرائيل نهايه الاسبوع
الماضي معربا عن امله في ان يؤدي الى خفض
التصعيد واشار برايس الى ان واشنطن تتفهم
مشاغل اسرائيل الامنيه لكنها قلقه من سقوط
عدد من الضحايا المدنيين
ابدى الاتحاد الاوروبي اسفه لوفاه مدنيين
في الضفه الغربيه داعيا جميع الاطراف الى
استعاده الهدوء لتجنب المزيد من الخسائر
في الارواح وقال الاتحاد في بيان انه يشعر
بقلق عميق من تصاعد العنف في الضفه
الغربيه واكد على ان استخدام القوه يجب ان
يكون متناسبا مع الاحترام الكامل للقانون
الانساني الدولي وان لا ياتي العنف الا
كملاذ اخير عندما لا يمكن تجنبه تماما
لحمايه الارواح وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
يؤيد بقوه البيان الرئاسي الصادر في
العشرين من هذا الشهر الذي اعتمده مجلس
الامن وانه يحس جميع الاطراف على الالتزام
به
معنى من تل ابيب امير اورين المحلل المختص
بشؤون الامن القومي وسياسه الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه سيد امير 11 شهيدا واكثر من
مئه جريح ماذا كانت تتوخى حكومه نتنياهو
من وراء كل ذلك
جديد هذه ماساه حقيقيه لكل الاطراف
اننا
من الواضح ان الثمن غالي جدا تقريبا مضت
السنه تحت
ثلاث رؤساء وزراء الذين كلهم واجهوا
النشاطات الارهابيه وخاصه في
غرب الشمال الباتينابلسجنيا وان الامن كان
لابد ان يتصرف بناء على معلومات حصلوا
عليها
ولكن
هذا كان مجرد اجراء مهني
بنتيجه هذه العمليات التي يقوم بها
هذا يمكن ما تسميه هو التبرير الواسع ولكن
لو مشينا على هذا الطريق فيمكن تبرير اي
شيء ولكن هذا لا يعني
ان موجه النشاطات التي شهدناها منذ الشهر
الماضي يمكن تبريرها بهذا فلو كانت هناك
هجمات
ضد اسرائيل
نتوقع
من العسكريين لا يردوا عليه شيء عن ذلك
واذا استمر الامر هكذا فاعتقد ان قوه
خارجيه مثل اداره بايدن مثلا يمكن ان تجبر
الرئيس عباس ورئيس الوزراء نتنياهو على
الجلوس الى مائده مفاوضات للتوصل الى
محادثات فعاله ومفيده طيب شكرا لك يا امير
اورين المحلل المختص بشؤون الامن القومي
والسياسه الخارجيه الاسرائيليه تل ابيب
قال المندوب الفلسطيني لدى الامم المتحده
رياض منصور ان اجتماعا سيعقد اليوم
للسفراء العرب لدى الامم المتحده لمناقشه
مساله التحرك في مجلس الامن الدولي فيما
يخص توفير الحمايه للشعب الفلسطيني اضاف
منصور انه نقل الى الامين العام للامم
المتحده اليوم تفاصيل مجزره نابلس وابلغه
بمطالب الشعب الفلسطيني المتمثله في انهاء
هذه المجازر وتوفير الحمايه الدوليه
نطالب والشعب الفلسطيني وقياده يطالب مجلس
الامن بتنفيذ قراراته في هذا الشان قرارات
المتعلقه بتوفير الحمايه بما فيها القرار
904 الذي اعتمد بعد مجزره الخليل عام
والتي جاء في ذلك القرار
نازع سلاح المستوطنين
وتواجد دولي مؤقت في كافه ارجاء الارض
الفلسطينيه المحتله
اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
عن قلقه العميق لسقوط قتلى وجرح في نابلس
خلال العمليه الامنيه الاسرائيليه واعرب
غوتشيرش عن قلقه ازاء التدابير العقابيه
التي اتخذتها اسرائيل ضد السلطه
الفلسطينيه وقال ان الحاله في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وصلت الى اعلى مستوى
من التوتر منذ سنوات
نلتقي والحاله في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله اكثر قابليه للاشتعال منذ سنوات
كانت هناك تطورات مقلقه بشده اسفرت عمليه
شنتها القوات الاسرائيليه وما عقب ذلك من
اشتباك في نابلس عم مقتل عشره فلسطينيين
واصابه اكثر من ثمانين تستمر دورات العنف
المميته في التسارع والتوترات مرتفعه
للغايه ولا تزال عمليه السلام متوقفه هذا
الوضع يثير عدم الاستقرار في جميع انحاء
المنطقه وخارجها
من رام الله معنا هاني المصري مدير مركزي
مسارات لابحاث السياسات ودراسات
الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك سيد هاني ما دلالات
هذه العمليه الواسعه والوحشيه التي نفذتها
اليوم قوات الاحتلال
اعتقد ان يعني هذه الدلالات تبدا برساله
قويه من قوات الاحتلال بانها غير معنيه
بالتفاهمات التي قيل انه تم الاتفاق عليها
مقابل يعني سحب الطلب الفلسطيني بالتصويت
على قرار ضد الاستيطان في مجلس الامن هذه
التفاهمات ظهرت على ارض الواقع كذب وحبر
على ورق وبدلا عنها لاحظنا ان هناك تصعيد
كبير جدا حتى اكثر من اي وقت مضى هناك 102
جرحى بالرصاص وهناك مئات الجرحى من
القنابل المثيره للدموع اضافه الى 11 شهيد
ارتقوا اليوم الكثير منهم مدنيين وليس لهم
علاقه حتى بالمقاومه رغم ان المقاومه
مشروعه بحكم القانون الدولي بحكم كافه
الشرائع الدينيه والدوليه لان هذا
الاحتلال يضرب البشر والحجر ويد مقدسات
ويحاول تغيير مكانه الاقصى ويقول ان هذه
الارض جزء من ارض اسرائيل المساله بالتالي
ليست عدم وجود عمليه سياسيه هناك حكومه ضم
وتهجير وتهويد وهذا الامر يتم تطبيقه هذا
اولا ثانيا الازمه التي تعاني منها
اسرائيل بحكم الخلاف حول يعني القضاء وحول
مدى الليبراليه التي يمكن ان تكون في
اسرائيل هذه الازمه كبيره جدا ومرشحه
للتصاعد فبالتالي تحاول حكومه نتنياهو ان
تصدر الازمه الى الخارج وبالتالي هناك
احتمال بالمزيد من التصعيد للمزيد من
الايغال بالدم الفلسطيني
يجب ان نرى يعني دكتور يعني عندما تقول ان
هذه التفاهمات ثبت انها كذب فيما يتعلق
بما حصل بين السلطه
والاحتلال
باعتقادك بعدما حدث اليوم كيف سينعكس ذلك
على تعامل السلطه مع ما يحدث
هناك يعني ما هو مفترض وهو ما هو متوقع
المفترض ان السلطه تاخذ موقفا في مستوى
التحدي في مستوى الدم الفلسطيني يتناسب مع
الموقف الشعبي الفلسطيني مع الحاجه
الفلسطينيه كيف يمكن ان تقيم قناه اتصال
بين السلطه والحكومه الاسرائيليه كما كشفت
المصادر المتعدده وتدعو العالم الى معاقبه
يعني هذه الحكومه اذا اردت ان يتعامل معك
العالم بشكل جدي عليك ان تكوني جديه وجديه
تقتضي مطالبه العالم
بعزل ومقاطعه وفرض العقوبات على هذه
الحكومه لان برنامجها هو برنامج متناقض مع
اي شيء عن عمليه السلام مع القانون الدولي
مع الاتفاقيات الموقعه وهو برنامج تصعيد
وحرب وبالتالي ينص على الحق الحصري لليهود
في استيطان الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
والجولان باعتبار كل ذلك جزء من ارض
اسرائيل وايضا هناك داخل هذه الحكومه من
يطرح شعارات وسياسات متطرفه جدا مثلج هو
يتبنى خطه اسمها خطه الحسم يتعامل ان على
الفلسطينيين امامهم ثلاثه خيارات الخيار
الاول ان يكونوا موالين لاسرائيل ويكونوا
مجرد رعايه بدون حقوق مواطن ثانيا ان يتم
تهجيرهم طواعيه او قصرا ثالثا من لا يريد
هذا ولا ذاك الجيش تكفل به ان يقتل هذا
الرجل اصبح وزير ماليه ووزير في وزاره
الحرب الاسرائيليه والمسؤول عن التعامل مع
الفلسطينيين والوزير اخر مسؤول عن الامن
الداخلي هو لا يقل تطرفا عن هذا الوزير
وهؤلاء حتى السلطه الفلسطينيه لا يريدون
استمرارها لانهم يريدون تفتيت السلطه الى
عده ادارات محليه حتى لا يكون هناك اي
اطار وطني يجمع الفلسطينيين وهناك خلاف
بينهم وبين نتنياهو نتني بقاء السلطه ولكن
يريد ان يحولها الى سلطه عميله بالكامل
خاضعه بالكامل لمقتضيات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اذا نحن امام مرحله جديده
حكومه تعتقد انها بمقدورها حسم الصراع
وتعتقد ان الحكومات الاسرائيليه السابقه
ترددت في هذه المساله وان بمقدورها النجاح
في حين ان ما يقوم به الشعب الفلسطيني من
صمود ومقاومه يدل على ان هذه
السياسات اوهام وستواجه برد فلسطين عاجلا
ام اجلا شكرا لك هذه المصري مدير مركز
مسارات لابحاث السياسات والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ضيفنا من رام الله
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي قام بعمل مهم لفتره طويله من
الزمن وانه من المهم ان يبقى الحلف متحدا
للتصدي لاي عدوان قادم واشار بايدن في
كلمه له خلال اجتماع لقاده دول الاعضاء في
النيتو الشرقيه اوروبا بالعاصمه البولنديه
وارسو الى زياده المساعدات لاوكرانيا
للدفاع عن سيادتها من جهته قال الامين
العام للنيتو يانسي ان الحلف لن يسمح
لروسيا بالانتصار وسيدافع عن كل شبر من
اراضي دول الاعضاء اضاف الصوت ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ليس مستعدا للسلم
وان على النيتو تعزيز دعمه لاوكرانيا
لتحقيق نصرها حسب تعبيره
بعد نحو عامل من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
عكس لقاء الرئيس الامريكي بقاده تسع دول
اعضاء في النيتو من اوروبا الشرقيه
والوسطى تشكل ما يسمى مجموعه بوخارست وجود
قلق لدى هذه الدول على مستقبل امن وسلامه
اراضها حيث تخللت الاجتماع دعوات لتعزيز
دفاعات هذه الدول لتكون قويه عند الحاجه
اليها وتعزيز الوجود الامريكي شرقي اوروبا
علما بان واشنطن نشرت اكثر من 20 الفا من
قواتها في اوروبا منذ بدء الحرب
اليوم وبحضور الرئيس بايدن نؤكد ماهيه
الالتزام من الاداره الامريكيه من اجل
تحقيق الامن للجانب الشرقي من حلف شمال
الاطلسي ونتطلع الى تعزيز الحضور الامريكي
في المنطقه والاستعداد الاستراتيجي من اجل
البحر الاسود الرئيس بايدن الرد برساله
طمانه اكد خلالها التزام بلاده بامن كل
شبر من دول النيتو
التزام الولايات المتحده بالنيتو واضح
تماما الماده الخامسه هي التزام مقدس
تعهدت به الولايات المتحده سندافع عن كل
شبر من النيتو هذه لحظه مهمه اتطلع فيها
الى المناقشات والخطوات التاليه التي يمكن
ان نتخذها معا للحفاظ على تحالفنا قويا
ولردع العدوان بشكل اكبر وما هو على المحك
بمعنى الكلمه ليس اوكرانيا فقط انها
الحريه من جانبه اكد الامين العام للحلف
عدم استعداد الرئيس للسلم مع اوكرانيا
وقال انه لا يمكن السماح لروسيا
بالاستمرار بتهديد امن اوروبا
لا نعلم متى ستنتهي الحرب لكن علينا ضمان
ان لا يعيد التاريخ نفسه بعد ذلك راينا
اسلوب العدوان الروسي في جورجيا وفي شبه
جزيره القرم ودومباس واستمراره في اجتياح
اوكرانيا لا يمكننا ان نسمح لروسيا
بمواصله تهديد الامن الاوروبي وعلينا
انهاء هذه الدوامه من العنف الروسي حلفاء
النيتو اليوم اكثر وحده من اي وقت مضى
وسندافع عن كل شبر فيه
وكان الرئيس بايدن قد القى خطابا منه مع
قرب حلول ذكرى الاولى لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اكد فيه دعم واشنطن راسخ لكل من
اوكرانيا واوروبا والسبق رحلته الى وارسو
بزياره الى كييف احيطت بالكثير من السريه
اكد خلالها دعم بلاده الذي لا يتزعزع
لجهود اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن اراضيها
نت جوله الرئيس بايدن اكثر من رساله وفي
اكثر من اتجاه لعل اهمها التاكيد على
تصميم الاداره الامريكيه على تعزيز الدفاع
المشترك للجناح الشرقي للنيتو وطمانه
اوكرانيا وجيرانها هي لاي اطماع توسعيه
مفترضه لموسكو في المرحله المقبله
وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون اوروبا
والنيتو ومن موسكو
عضو مجلس ادومه الروسي مرحبا بكم سيد
افقيني كيف راقبت موسكو هذا الاجتماع
للتسعه في بوخارست وهذا التعهد بتمتين
الجبهه الشرقيه
من حق النيتو ان يتوسع يعني اليست هذه في
غير المصلحه الروسيه
توسع الناتو في هذه المناطق شيء ليس للناس
حقا فيه اما تقويه الجناح الشرقي فهذا حق
لهم تماما كما لدينا الحق ان نقوي وندعم
قوتنا على اراضنا اما التوسع شيء ليس
لديهم حق فيه قامت الناتو بالتوسع في
البلطيق ودول البطيخ ايضا دول غير شرعيه
حسب قوانين الدوليه بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه لذلك على الناتو علينا ان نخرج ان
هذه الاراضي ونعلم جيدا كيف نقوم بهذا
ونفهم اننا
منذ الامس علقنا العمل باتفاق تحديد
الاسلحه النوويه
والان
نعتقد ان الاراضي الامريكيه والاوروبيه هي
مستهدفه من قواتنا النوويه
ما قاله السيد بوتين منذ سنتين اننا لدينا
الحق الدفاع عن انفسنا ويجب ان نحرر
اوكرانيا ودول البلطيق واوكرانيا وروسيا
تعمل حسب الخطاب
لماذا يعتبر الرئيس الامريكي ان هذا
التمتين للجبهه الشرقيه للنيتو هو راضع
حقيقه لروسيا
اعتقد ان الكثير ما يقوم به الناتو حاليا
وما تقوم به الولايات المتحده الثنائيه في
اوروبا هو نتيجه مباشره للغزل الروسي
لاوكرانيا والقرر ان قلق هذه الدول التي
على حدود روسيا بانهم قد يكون التاليين او
ما بعدها بعد اوكرانيا وبالتالي
طمعنه هؤلاء وحمايتهم من روسيا لذلك نقلوا
قواتهم الى هذه البلدان والاقل في قوات
دفاعيه تماما لطمانه هذه الدول وانهم
سيحضن بالحمايه وللردعه
اي عدوان روسيين اخر في اوروبا وهذا هو
كله نتيجه الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا ولو
الروسيه
الروحيه تحديدا هي ما ادت اساسا الى الحرب
في اوكرانيا كما تقول موسكو عندما بدا
الحديث عن امكانيه توسع الناتو الى
اوكرانيا
زاد ذلك من توجه ساتي موسكو مما ادى الى
هذه الحرب لماذا سيختلف وفق وجهه نظر
المسؤولين في النيتو لماذا سيختلف هذا
الامر هذه المره مع تمتين الجبهه الشرقيه
ان اوكرانيا هي دوله ذات السياده
واوكرانيا
طلبت الاحتمال انضمامها الاتحاد الاوروبي
لاوكرانيا الحق في القيام بذلك اما روسيا
فليس لديها الحق بان تملي على اوكرانيا ما
تقوم به روسيا غزت اوكرانيا لان روسيا
ارادت من اوكرانيا ان تصبح تحت سيطرتها
الرئيس بوتين اراد ان يقول لك كيف يعملوا
ما يعملوه وهذا قد اتفقنا جميعا في محاكم
السنكي بان السياده
كانت امر لا يمكن انتهاكه ولا يمكن يحصل
اي شيء لاي دوله ذات السياده روسيا
والاتحاد السوفيتي وافقوا على ذلك هذا
مكان تقوم به اوكرانيا اي ممارسه حقها
السياده بالطلب من الاتحاد الاوروبي
امكانيه
اريد فقط ان انوه الى اننا نشاهد في هذه
الاثناء هذه الصور مباشره من الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده في جلسه تعقد حول
اوكرانيا ويتحدث في هذه الاثناء
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني اعود اليك سيد
فودروف في موسكو اذا يقول ضيفنا من
الولايات المتحده ان هذا التمتين للنيتو
ياتي بنتيجه مباشره للغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا الا يبرهن ذلك ان هذه الحرب
الروسيه اتت بنتيجه عكسيه لما تريده موسكو
اسمعوني نحن نفهم جيدا ان المشكله تقع فيه
واشنطن بالطبع يجب ان نحل هذه المشكله مع
واشنطن وليس مع كيف بالنسبه لواشنطن لدينا
معدات خاصه
اذا بدانا في المرحله الثانيه من هذا
التجهيز سوف نستهدف
الولايات المتحده وقطاعاتها وعندها اعتقد
ان
المهاجرين سوف يبداون بالرحيل من امريكا
وسوف يعترضوا على سياسه الرئيس بايدن
لدينا امكانيات
كان لدينا امكانيه اقل من الامكانيات
الامريكيه ب 20 مره ولكن الان نحن اصبحنا
في نفس المستوى لذلك نحن لا نتخلى عن
القوانين الدوليه لان العدوان كان ضدنا
نحن واكرر هنا ان اوكرانيا منطقه غير
شرعيه منذ قوانين الحرب العالميه الثانيه
شكرا
جزيلا لك وشكرا للسيد جيم تاونزن نائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق لشؤون
اوروبا والنيت ضيفنا من واشنطن
قالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان الوزير
سرجيايلاف روف ورئيس مكتب لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه للجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي
الصيني لم يناقشا في اجتماع في موسكو خطه
ما تسمى بالتسويه الصينيه بشان اوكرانيا
وكانت تقارير قد تحدثت عن تحضير الصين خطه
للتسويه وقال متحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
بعد لقائه الرئيس الروسي في موسكو ان
بيجين ستقوم بدور محايد وموضوعيا وبناء
بين روسيا واوكرانيا وتعيد هذه التطورات
الى الواجهه ما جرى على مدى عام كامل من
محاولات لوقف الحرب من خلال مفاوضات
مباشره وغير المباشره
بعد اربعه ايام فقط من بدء الحرب على
اوكرانيا سارعت موسكو وكياف الى الجلوس
وجها لوجه على طاوله المفاوضات في
بيلاروسيا لكن الجولات الخمسه التي عقدت
هناك انتهت دون تحقيق تقدم يمكن الركود
اليه باستثناء تفاهمات على فتح ممرات
انسانيه تسمح بخروج المدنيين من اتون
المعارك لكن اكثر المحاولات المعلنه جديه
كانت تلك التي استضافتها تركيا حيث التقى
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سركيلافروف نظيره
الاوكراني ديمتروكوليبا بحضور الوسيط
التركي مولود شاوج اوغلو فكان ذلك
الاجتماع ارفع تواصل علني بين الجانبين
منذ بدايه الحرب
لعبت تركيا دورا محوريا في تقريب وجهات
النظر مستانده الى علاقاتها الوثيقه بطرفي
الحرب واستطاعت جمع وفدي البلدين لكنها لم
توفق في الخروج باتفاق ينهي الحرب
غير انها استطاعت انجاز ما عرف باتفاق
الحبوب الذي اتاح تصدير ملايين الاطنان من
الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود وهو
ما جنب العلم ازمه غذائيه حاده ومنذ ذلك
الوقت جرى الحديث عن جهود دبلوماسيه لوضع
قطار التفاوض على سكته مره اخرى لكن هذه
المحاولات جرت في ظل نزال عسكري كان كل
طرف فيه يرفع شروط التفاوض في كل مره احرز
فيها كسبا عسكريا على الارض
الجانب الاوكراني الذي حقق مكاسب عسكريه
مهمه كبحت التقدم الروسي على طول الجبهه
حضر على نفسه التفاوض مع الرئيس بوتين
طالما هو في موقع الرئاسه ووضع مزيدا من
الخطوط الحمراء اقلها استعاده كامل
السياده في المقابل رفعت موسكو سقف خطوطها
الحمراء لسيما بعد ضمها اربع مناطق في شرق
اوكرانيا بحيث اصبحت جزءا من اراضي
الاتحاد الروسي لا يمكن التنازل عنه وفق
دستورها الوطني في روسيا من مات يؤكد ان
الحديث عن الخطوط الحمراء بات من الماضي
والا رجوع عن تحقيق كامل اهداف العمليه
العسكريه هذا في وقت تترسخ ولد الغرب
قناعه بان دعمه العسكريه لاوكرانيا لابد
منه لجر موسكو الى التفاوض على الاقل
والحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بها في نهايه
المطاف
البرلمان الاوكراني ان الرئيس زيلينسكي
طرح خطه للسلامه خلال لقاءات قمه العشرين
واكد كورنكو في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره
ترحيب اوكرانيا بجهود احلال السلام لكنه
اشترط خضوع المبادرات للشروط التي طرحها
الرئيس الاوكراني
خلال لقاءاته في قمه العشرين ستناقش هذه
الخطه بشكل موسع في الايام المقبله مع
الامم المتحده وسنوصلها لجميع المنتديات
الدوليه علينا ان نقوم بخطوات مثل تحديد
التهديدات النوويه مثلا وقضايا الامن
والغذاء ويجب ان تحل هذه المسائل باخراج
القوات الروسيه من جميع اراضينا ونرحب
بجهود الشركاء لاحلال السلم لكن على اساس
الشروط التي طرحها الرئيس زيلينسكي
وال السياسيه مرحبا بك سيد رونج روان يقول
الرئيس بوتين امام وزير الخارجيه الصيني
ان العلاقات بين البلدين تصل الى افاق
جديده ما هي هذه الافاق
اهلا ومرحبا بكم يبدو ان الصوره لا تتحرك
هل تسمع صوتي
التطور
للشراكه استراتيجيه الشامل بين الصين
وروسيا وتتطور باستمرار
وان هذا
التعاون يعني لا استغفر لها وكذلك هذا
التعاون لا يستهدف الى اي طرف الثالث وهو
يعني سيعود هذا تعاوني الى يعني
الشعبين البلدين وكذلك يساعد على حفاظ
السلام والسلمي في المنطقه ولكن هل هذا
التعاون ما يتعلق بالحرب على اوكرانيا لان
وكاله الانباء الروسيه نقلت ان وزير
الخارجيه الصينيه يقول ان الصين ملتزمه
بمبدا الحياد وتحاول لعب دور بناء في
تسويه الازمه
طبعا في
بخصوص ازمه اوكرانيا
دائما
وموقفها دائم ومستمر وواضحه وهو ان السن
تدعو الى حل السلمي او ايجاني حل سلمي عبر
التفاوت
وكذلك وقف اطلاق النار
العوده الى الطاولات المفاوضات وكذلك يعني
التحديات الوضع والتحيه الظروف
لبدل المفاوضات
لماذا جرى تجنب البحث في خطه سلام صينيه
كان يتحدث وزير الخارجيه الصيني عن ان
بلاده تمتلكها على هامش مؤتمر ميونخ
طبعا يعني حتى الان لم يتم اعلان
التفاصيلها بشكل رسمي ولكن
هناك يعني هناك استجابه من كل من
اوكرانيا وروسيا وكذلك هناك اجتماع
بينه وكذلك رئيس بوتين
وايضا اعربت
الروسي ان يعني
استعدادها كذلك
للتفاوض فهذا ايضا استجابه للدعوه الصينيه
وكان
الصين يعني تقدر يعني تقدم تقديرا للناقص
الروسي لاستعداد للتفاوض شكرا لك الرنج
الاعلامي والبحث السياسي ضيفنا من بيجين
[موسيقى]
تعاون ولوم تستقبل بهما طهران مفتشي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذين
وصلوا الثلاثاء لبحث ملفات عالقه لا تكف
ايران عن تاكيد التعاون مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بموازاه رفض متجدد
لما تعتبره ضغوطا سياسيه او تنفيذا
للاتفاق النووي من طرف واحد الزياره
الحاليه لمفتشين الوكاله جاءت على وقع
اتهامات بشان اكتشاف نسب تخصيب عاليه
لليورانيوم سارع المسؤولون الايرانيون
بنفيها
من الوكاله موجودون في ايران وبداوا بضيوم
امس مناقشه الاتهامات الموجهه الينا بشان
كشف يورانيوم
وهذه الاتهامات ناتجه عن تقارير خاطئه من
احد مفتشي الوكاله
يوم الاحد الماضي نشرت وكاله بلومبيرج
مذكره لدبلوماسيين افادت ان وكاله الطاقه
الذريه رصدت بايران يورانيوم مخصبا بنسبه
84% وهي نسبه تقارب المستوى المطلوب لصنع
سلاح نووي اثر ذلك رد مسؤولون في وكاله
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ان بلادهم ملتزمه
بنسبه 60% للتخصيب وان وجود يورانيوم مخصب
بنسب تتجاوز ذلك امر طبيعي اثناء عمليه
التخصيب وان العبره بالمنتج النهائي
انتقدت طهران ما تقول انه تسييس لعمل
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وابتعاد عن
دورها الفني تردد هذا اللوم في تصريحات
وزير الخارجيه الايراني الذي ندد ايضا
بمعتبرها رسائل متناقضه من الطرف الامريكي
بشان العوده للاتفاق النووي
مستعدون لاتمام مباحثات فيينا لكننا نتلقى
رسائل متناقضه من الطرف الامريكي تكون اي
عبر القنوات الدبلوماسيه ومتنقطه عبر
تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين في الاعلام لوح
عبد اللهيان بما سماها الخطه باء اذا اتخذ
الطرف الامريكي وفق قوله منحا مختلفا
مؤكدا اللانيه لبلاده في امتلاك قنبله
نوويه منذ 2018 تتهم طهران الجانب
الامريكي باجهاض الاتفاق النووي حين
انسحبت منه اداره ترامب وهي تبدي طوال
الوقت ترحيبها بالعوده بشرط رفع العقوبات
والا يكون السير باتجاه اتفاق جديد غير ما
ابرم عام 2015 بينما يتهمها خصومها
بخروقات عديده للاتفاق الاصلي وبانشطه
عسكريه وسياسيه اقليميه غير مرحب بها
غربيا
معنى من طهران هادي افقهي الدبلوماسي
الايراني السابق ومن ولايه فرجينيا معنى
الرئيس التنفيذي لمعهد كوينسي ومستشار
الرئيس اوباما خلال المفاوضات النوويه
مرحبا بكم سنبدا معك سيد هادي افقهي ما
الرساله من وراء هذا التعاون مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في هذه المرحله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي للجميع
الرساله هو انه
وكاله الطاقه الذريه خرجت عن مسارها
الحرفي والمهني
واصبحت هناك مشاكل يجب الان حلها وخصوصا
فيما يتعلق بادعاءات السيد رافع عندما زار
اسرائيل واتابي روايه اسرائيليه موساديه
من ان هناك ثلاث مواقع تخفي ايران نشاطها
في هذه المواقع الثلاثه وفي النهايه اقرت
وكاله الطاقه الذريه من مكانه هناك اخطاء
في تقييمات وفي تقارير رفعها وفتش الطاقه
الذريه القائمون المقيمين في طهران والان
كذلك لقط اخر هو اتهام ايران بتخصيب
اليورانيوم بنسبه
84% في حين انه ايران عندما ارادت ان تخصب
بنسبه 60% اعلنت وكاله الطاقه نريد ان
نخصص بنسبه 60% التي تشكك انت اليوم في
مصداقيتها وتقول انها باتت مسيسه وفد منها
يقوم بالتفتيش حاليا في ايران
نعم عندما اعلنت الوكاله انها تريد ان
تتعامل بحرفيه استقبلت ايران هذه الفكره
ورحبت حتى بزياره السيد جروس الذي ابدى
رغبته لزياده العاصمه طهران وزياره
المنشات وحل هذه في الحقيقه المشكله
الفنيه التي تحصل اثناء التخصيب وليس
المنتج النهائي للتخصيب
ما هي الرساله التي تلقتها الولايات
المتحده ودول الغرب من وراء هذه الخطوه
الايرانيه
ما هي
المؤشرات التي التقطتها الولايات المتحده
من وراء الخطوه الايرانيه
اعتقد اولا انه اي من هذا ما كان اللي
يحصل لو ان الولايات المتحده لم تنسحب من
الاتفاق النووي اصلا وطبعا من وجدت نظر
امريكيه حاليا العوده الى هذا الاتفاق لن
يكون ممكنا الا اذا قامت الوكاله الدوليه
بحل وايران بحل نزاعاتهم خلافاتهما من
وجهه نظر امريكا ليس هناك تعاون كافي من
جانب الايراني مع الوكاله الدوليه فاذا
كانك خطوات وزيارات قامت روسيا وغيرها من
شانها ان تدفع بالكره الى الامام تحل بعض
القضايا ولكن لاجد صعوبه في ان اعتبر ان
تعتبر جانب الامريكي ذلك حاليا ان امريكا
متشائمه او تشكك برغبه ايران حقا بحل كل
هذه المشاكل دون ان تقدم طلبات لا يمكن
وكاله الدوليه قبول بها ولكن في نهايه
المطاف حتى في الظرف الحالي يبدو لي ان
الجانب الامريكي يفهم بان العوده الى
اتفاق النووي وحل بعض هذه المشاكل هو فعلا
افضل طريقه افضل مخرج حتى الولايات
المتحده
لو كان لدى امريكا اراده سياسيه كافيه
للتخاذ هذا القرار او الاستئناف المفاوضات
مع ايران هذا اذا ما حصلت سيكون موضوع
مختلف سيد هذه افقه هي هل تامل ايران ان
تنعكس هذه الخطوه التي اتخذت اليوم
باستقبال هذا الوفد من الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه ان تنعكس على المفاوضات في
فيينا التي وصلت كما يبدو الى طريق مسدود
يعني هناك
مؤشرات اخرى سيدتي تشجع الطرفين للرجوع
الى طابه المفاوضات وهي خبر زياده السلطان
عمان السيد هيثم بن طارق الى طهران وهو
يحمل رساله واستبشر بها السيد امير عبد
الله
وكذلك التقاء وزير الخارجيه العراقي السيد
فؤاد حسين بعد رجوعه من واشنطن الى في
بغداد ولقائه بامر عبد الله هذا اليوم
وكذلك قبله سبق كل هذه المحاولات السيد
محمد بن عبد الرحمن وزير خارج القطري كذلك
حمد رساله من الطرف الامريكي انه تريد
امريكا ان ترجع لاطابه المفاوضات فهذه
المؤشرات والاصرار على التهدئه فيما يتعلق
بالتهديدات الاسرائيليه لضرب ايران بعد ان
هي اعلنت انه ايران وصلت الى نسبه التخصيب
84 هناك مؤشرات ايجابيه لا ن نبني عليها
مئه بالمئه ولكن كانت مشجعه وخصوصا الان
طهران تنتظر الرساله التي سيحملها سلطان
عمان الى طهران سيد بارسي وزير
يقول ان هناك رسائل متناقضه تصل الى
المسؤولين الايرانيين من طرف الولايات
المتحده بينما يقال من جانب الوسطاء
وبينما يقال في العلم
اعتقد انه من جانب الايراني قد يرون انها
سائل متناقضه بمعنى انه من جانب الجانب
الامريكي يقول ان الكره في ملعب ايران في
حين انه الولايات المتحده تقول بشكل بان
العوده الى المفاوضات حاليا ليس اولويه
لامريكا وهذا وهذا هذه تعتبر رسائل
متناقضه بطرق مختلفه لكن المهم ان هذه
الرساله اللي قدمها القطريون او العراقيون
والعمانيين الى ايران انا لست مطلعا عليها
ولكنني اعتقد ان لو ان الجانب الايراني
كان مهتما باستئناف المفاوضات فيبدو لي
ان اسهل طريقه للقيام بذلك هو ان يقوم
الجانب الايراني بالعوده والقول بانهم
يقبلون المقترح للطرح عليهم في شهر اغسطس
الماضي
عن ذاك اولا ايران قالوا انه موافق على
ذلك قرروا التغييرات على ذلك تلك
التقريرات وضعت من وجهه نظر ايرانيه كانت
لم تكن مبرره وغير معقوله لكن المهم هو
انها ان المفاوضات حول الاتفاق قد كلف
الطرفين
اشياء كثيره في الاقتصاد لايران الان اسوا
بكثير مكائن ليس فقط يعد غياب الاتفاق
بسبب الاحتجاجات الجاريه الداخلي ايران
وهذا يثبت بان كلفه الانتظار
رئيسه التنفيذي لمعهد كوينسي ومستشار
الرئيس اوباما خلال المفاوضات النوويه
ضيفنا من فيرجينيا وشكرا للسيد هادي
الايراني السابق ضيفنا من طهران
[موسيقى]
قال رضا بلحاج القيادي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه المعارضه في تونس ان قوات امنيه
اقتحمت منزل عصام الشاب الامين العام
الحزب الجمهوري المعارض واعتقلته وقال
نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه الخلاص وشقيق عصام
الشاب ان مجموعه من عشرين عنصرا امنيا
اعترضوا شقيقه عصام عندما كان برفقه زوجته
في الشارع واعتقلوه بعد تفتيش منزله وقد
دانت حركه النهضه اعتقال الشاب واعتبرته
اعتداء جديدا على احد رموز المعارضه لما
وصفته بالانقلاب الغاشم وياتي اعتقال
الشاب ضمن سلسله اعتقالات تشنها السلطات
التونسيه على معارضين لاجراءات الرئيس قيس
سعيد شملت سياسيين واعلاميين ورجال اعمال
وقضاه ومحامين ويعد الشاب ارفع سياسيا من
حيث الصفه الحزبيه يعتقل حتى الان كما
افادت مصادر حقوقيه تونسيه باعتقال
القياديه في جبهه الخلاص المعارضه شيماء
عيسى
وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان هناك
حملات وصفها بالمسعوره من اشخاص قال انهم
ماجورون من الخارج لضرب الدوله التونسيه
على حد تعبيره اضاف سعيد انه يخوض حرب
تحرير وطني داعيا القضاء الى القيام بدوره
وتطبيق القانون على الجميع
ويحبو يرجعوا يدخل للشعب كما الادويه
بالضبط اللي انتهت مده صلاحيتها ولا بعض
الاغذيه لدى انتهت مده السلوقيتها ايضا
مده سلوحيتهم ولذلك تراهم
وثم
الحملات المسعوره بتاع الناس الماجورين
وعملاء
للخارج ولجهاد المشبوهه لضرب الدوله
التونسيه
وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه يتابع بقلق
التطورات الاخيره في تونس التي اعتبرها
جاره قريبه جدا تربطه معها شراكه عميقه
واستراتيجيه اضاف في بيان ان تونس تمر
بلحظه حساسه ويامل الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
تتمكن السلطات التونسيه من العثور على
الحلول المناسبه للعديد من التحديات
الحاليه والمستقبليه التي تواجهها البلاد
وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه كشريك طويل
الامد قلق للغايه بشان التدهور الوضع
الاقتصادي في تونس على وجه الخصوص والاثر
الاجتماعي الذي قد يسببه ذلك اضاف انه يجب
ان تعمل القوى السياسيه والاجتماعيه
المختلفه في تونس معا في مشروع مشترك
وشامل للبلاد وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
على استعداد لدعم جهود التونسيه من اجل
الاصلاحات الهيكليه العاجله التي ستجريها
البلاد
معنا من تونس مدير مكتب الجزيره لطفي حجي
لطفي مرحبا بك ماذا في اخر التطورات
المتعلقه بالملاحقات والتوقيفات وردود
الفعل عليها
نعم ال سي هي ايقافات متسارعه كانت عصام
الشابي ثم حديث الحقوقين عن اعتقال شيماء
عيسى
وكذلك هناك تطويق لمنزل جوهر مبارك
القيادي بجبل خلاص في بنيه اعتقاله لكن
غير لكنه غير موجود في
المنزل هذه
الاعتقالات تاتي في سياق اوسف
بالمتشنج
والذي ادى الى اعتقال مجموعه من السياسيين
السابقين وحسب بعض المعطيات المتوفره فان
هذه الاعتقال تدخل لها علاقه
بالناشط السياسي المعتقل خيام التركي الذي
سبق له ان اجتمع بمجموعه من القيادات
الحزبيه والنشطاء بغايه القيام بمؤدره
لتوحيد
المعارضه بعض المعطيات المتوفره لحد الان
تقول انه ليس من مستبعد ان يتم اعتقال من
شارك في هذه الاجتماعات الى حد الان هناك
اربعه تم اعتقالهم في هذا
الملف في انتظار ما ستسفر عنه الايام
القادمه او الساعات القادمه لكن هذه
الاجراءات في الحقيقه رغم ان الرئيس
الدوله يعتبرها دائما بانها محاوله
لمواجهه من انتهت صلاحيتهم ومواجهتهم
ارتباطات بالخارج رئيس الدوله دائما يتحدث
فيها سياق دون ان يسمي لكن مفهوم ان يقصد
هؤلاء لكنها تثير
قلقا كبيرا هنا في تونس سواء في اوساط
الحقوقيين هناك كثير من المواقف الحقيقيه
ليس صدرت في الاوساط السياسيه لاحظنا انه
الحزب الجمهوري حركه النهضه وغيرها اصدرت
بيانات في هذا الصدد وكذلك على المستوى
الدولي موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي كان واضحا
اليوم في الحديث على ضروره ايجاد حل في
هذا السياق للازمه سواء على المستوى
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي وكذلك على المستوى
السياسي لكن ليس هناك بوادر للحوار حتى ان
المبادره التي يعتزم اتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل اطلاقها ليس هناك اي تفاعل معها على
المستوى الرسمي بل عكس من ذلك كان الرئيس
يتساءل سواء اليوم او قبل ذلك مع من سيتم
الحوار وكان على الذين يدعون الحوار ان
يتوجهوا الى شعب ويطلعون على الظروف هذا
الشعب حسب تعبيره نعم على كل سيكون لنا
توسع في هذا الملف ملف تونس وكامل
التداعيات
تداعيات هذه الاعتقادات في الساعه الثانيه
من الحصاد شكرا لك لطفي حاج مدير مكتب
الجزيره في تونس
منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه المكرمه واذي ابرز
العناوين في حصاد الليله
تصعيد اسرائيلي دام في الضفه الغربيه هو
الاعنف منذ سنوات قوات الاحتلال تقتل عشره
فلسطينيين خلال اقتحام مدينه نابلس في
عمليه لافته في حجمها وعدد الجرحى يتجاوز
100 عرين الاسود تتوعد والقسام تحذر من
نفاذ صبر المقاومه والسلطه تطالب مجلس
الامن بحمايه دوليه للشعب الفلسطيني يحذر
من التداعيات وقلق امريكي من ارتفاع مستوى
العنف
دائره الاعتقالات في تونس الحزب الجمهوري
يعلن توقيف امنه العام عصام الشاب والامن
يعتقل قياديه بارزه في جبهه الخلاص
المعارضه الرئيس سعيد يتحدث عن حملات
مسعوره من اشخاص يقول انهم ماجورون من
الخارج لضرب الدوله والاتحاد الاوروبي
يعرب عن قلقه ويقول ان البلاد بحاجه الى
حلول لتحدياتها
اجتماع غير مسبوق لقاده الجناح الشرقي
للنيتو برئاسه بايدن بوتين يعتبر حرب
روسيا في اوكرانيا دفاعا عما سماه اراضيها
التاريخيه ومع حديث عن مبادره تسويه صينيه
تقول انها تقبل باي اقتراحات دوليه للسلام
شرط ان تكون وفق شروطها
بعد تقارير عن تجاوزات في انشطه ايران
النوويه وفد من خبراء الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه في طهران ايران ترفض اي
ضغوط سياسيه بشان انشطتها النوويه تؤدي
الى التزامات من طرف واحد وتنفي اي محاوله
لتخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه اكبر من 60%
ووزير خارجيتها يقول ان بلاده مستعده
لاتمام مباحثات فيينا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد احد
عشر فلسطينيا واصابه اكثر من 100 اخرين
حالات بعضهم خطره بالاضافه لاكثر من 250
حاله اختناق بالغاز المسيل للدموع خلال
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مدينه
نابلس الشماليه ضفت الغربيه وقد اندلعت
اشتباكات مسلحه بين مقاومين فلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال التي حاصرت منزلا بذريعه
اعتقال مطلوبين هذا واعلنت سرايا القدس
التابعه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي استشهاد
قائد كتيبه نابلس محمد ابو بكر جنيدي خلال
المواجهات
هذا البيت المتاكل في المدينه العتيقه في
نابلس كان هدف العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه
قصفه الاحتلال بالصواريخ وفجر الجدران
والهدف قتل المقاومين حسام سليم ومحمد
جنيدي بعد ان رفضاه تسليما نفسيهما
انفجارات زي صواريخ يعني بيوت قديمه
تفاجانا بعد ثلاث اربع ساعات انه صوت
انفجار مش مسترجين نطلع له مستشهدين ناس
بقلب البيت اللي جنبنا
قتل المقاومان بزعم انهما من قاده عرين
الاسود ونفذا هجمات ضد جنود ومستوطنين
وكان مع رفاقهما يخططان للمزيد
اما خارج ازقه البلده القديمه فاستخدم
الاحتلال الرصاص الحي
استهدف مقاومين ولم يكتفي بذلك
بل اطلق النار مباشره على مدنيين فقتله
مسنين ومنع الطواقم الطبيه من الوصول الى
الجرحى تحاول الحكومه الاسرائيليه كما
يبدو تصدير ازمتها الداخليه عبر الخوض
والدمج الفلسطيني والدفع باتجاه التصعيد
قد
تنفلت اموره هذه ناحيه والناحيه الثانيه
ان الاعتبار الامني عند اسرائيل اهم من اي
اتفاقيات او تفاهمات حتى لو كانت
بوساطه دوليه
وفي خضم جنازه شارك فيها الالاف وتقدمها
مئات المقاومين اكدت عناصر مجموعات عرين
الاسود وكتيبه بلاطه انهم ماضون على درب
الشهداء في المقاومه
القياده الفلسطينيه اكدت انها ستتوجه
مجددا الى مجلس الامن الدولي خاصه بعد ان
ضربت الحكومه الاسرائيليه بعرض الحائط
التفاهمات السياسيه اما الاحتلال فرفع
درجه التاهب خاصه القبه الحديديه بعد
التهديدات التي اعلنتها فصائل المقاومه
كافه
هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون ما حدث فالاحتلال لم
يقتل مقاومين فقط بل استهدف مدنيين بينهم
مسنون عمليه تاتي براي كثيرين ضمن محاوله
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تصديم ازمتها
الداخليه حتى وان سرع ذلك من الوصول الى
لحظه الانفجار الجزيره نابلس
قال وزير الامن القومي تمارن انه اوعز
للمفتش العام للشرطه الاسرائيليه بتعزيز
قوات الشرطه في كافه انحاء اسرائيل في
اعقاب عمليه نابلس واشاد بنجزير في تغريده
بقوات جيش الاحتلال والقوات الخاصه
والشباب الذين قاموا بقتل من وصفهم
بالمخربين وقال ان اسرائيل ستستمر في
ملاحقه من يحاول المساس بها وستوجه لهم
ضربه ساحقه
اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
قلق بلاده من ان يؤدي الهجوم على نابلس
الى تراجع جهود اعاده الاستقرار اضاف نادي
برايس ان الولايات المتحده قلقه من مستوى
العنف في الضفه الغربيه واسرائيل وانها
تحث الجانبين الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني على
وقف الاعمال التي تشعل التوتر ورحب برايس
بالتفاهم الذي توصل اليه
الفلسطينيون
واسرائيل نهايه الاسبوع الماضي معربا عن
امله ان يؤدي الى خفض التصعيد واشار برايس
الى ان واشنطن تتفهم مشاغل اسرائيل
الامنيه لكنها قلقه من سقوط عدد من
الضحايا المدنيين
ابدى الاتحاد الاوروبي اسفه لوفاه مدنيين
في الضفه الغربيه داعيا جميع الاطراف الى
استعاده الهدوء لتجنب المزيد من الخسائر
في الارواح وقال الاتحاد في بيان انه يشعر
بقلق عميق من تصاعد العنف في الضفه
الغربيه وكذا ان استخدام القوه يجب ان
يكون متناسبا مع الاحترام الكامل للقانون
الانساني الدولي والا ياتي العنف الا
كملاذ اخيرا عندما لا يمكن تجنبه تماما
لحمايه الارواح وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه
يؤيد بقوه البيان الرئاسيه الصادر في
العشرين من هذا الشهر الذي اعتمده مجلس
الامن وانه يحث جميع الاطراف على الالتزام
به
معنا من غزه الدكتور صالح النعامي الخبير
في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومعنى من واشنطن
المتحدث السابق باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه مرحبا بكما دكتور صالح النعامي
كيف قرات الرسائل التي ارادت حكومه
نتنياهو المتشدده ان ترسلها من وراء هذا
هذه العمليه الواسعه في نابلس رسائل الى
الفلسطينيين والى العالم والى الداخل
الاسرائيلي كذلك
يعني في الحقيقه هذه المجزره التي ارتكبها
جيش الاحتلال اليوم تاتي في اطار
سعي الحكومه الاكثر تطرفا والاكثر يمنيه
في تاريخ اسرائيل
لتحقيق استراتيجيه الواضحه وحسم الصراع
هذه الحكومه يعني تختلف عن كل الحكومات
الاسرائيليه ليتعاقبت على الحكم مثل عام
1967 التي اشتغلت
وحكمتها استراتيجيه اداره الصراع هذه
الحكومه تاتي لحسم الصراع وضمن ذلك تجفيف
بيئه المقاومه في اي مكان بكل بكل بكل قوه
بشكل نهائي وطبعا هذا الذي يفسر تلك
المجزره البشعه التي ارتكبت اليوم في
نابلس ايضا هناك الاعتبار الداخلي الحكومه
بنيامين تواجه اكبر حركه احتجاج داخلي في
تاريخ الكيان الصهيوني بسبب ما يسمى
الاصلاحات القضائيه التي الهادفه الى
اخراج ومحاوله توفير ملاذ لبنيامين
نتنياهو من المحاكم في قضايا الفساد لذلك
وشركائه في من اليمين الديني المتطرف
معنيين يعني تغليب الاجنده الامنيه على
على الاجندات الاخرى لذلك هم معنيين يعني
تركيزة
تسطيط الضوء على الجانب الامني عن طريق
مثل هذه
المجازر بالمناسبه هذا يتوقف فقط في نابلس
ما يحدث ايضا في محيط القدس في شعفاط هنا
جرائم لا يعني كبرى تدمير المنازل فرض
القيود على الحركه تدمير المنازل في منطقه
مسافر جنوب الخليل وغور الاردن القيود في
المسجد الاقصى
قرارات المنازل في مستوطنات وهذا امر يعني
يهدف الى حسم حسم مصير الارض الفلسطينيه
ايضا
الولايات المتحده تطالب بامور اصلا هذه
الحكومه حكومه نتنياهو لا تعترف بها يعني
يتم مطالبه بالعوده الى قضيه حل الدولتين
يتم المطالبه باحترام التفاهمات بين
اسرائيل والسلطه الفلسطينيه اصلا هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا تعترف بكل ذلك
وتنقلب عليه في كل فرصه وهي كما قال لك
سيد صالح النعامي تعتزم حسم الصراع عسكريا
كيف ينظر الى هذا الامر في الولايات
المتحده
اعتقد اننا نراه الان هو ضعف حكومه
نتنياهو والتناقضات التي هي موجوده داخل
الحكومه على سبيل المثال في الايام
القليله الماضيه وبدفع من الحكومه
الامريكيه الحكومه نتنياهو قالت انها لن
توافق على بناء المزيد من المستوطنات
الضفه الغربيه وهي ايماءه تحس النيه تجاه
الولايات المتحده هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى
نرى كل هذا عمليه
الكبح الامنيه
ونتنياهو يحاول ان يفعل كذا الامرين
المتناقضين سويه ارضاء واسترضاء المتحده
وحسب الامور امنيا وعسكريا هي قضيه من
يتخذ خطوه الى الامام ثم خطوه الى الوراء
وكيف تن الولايات المتحده التعامل مع ذلك
كما قال النابلس الراس المتحده تعبر عن
قلقها لكن من المهم جدا ان نؤكد على ان كل
اداره من اداره الامريكيه من حتى انا خدمت
في اداره
كلينتن واداره اوباما
لديهم
مبعوث رئاسي شخصي يكلف
بمحاوله دفع عمليه الحل عمليه حل الاساس
الدولتين امر ملاحظ ان اداره سبادل لم
تعين شخصا بهذه الصفه لانها لا ترى حل
الدولتين حلا
المجديا رغم ان الولايات المتحده تعتبر
هذا الحل هو السبيل الامثل للامام اذا
الحل لهذا التحدي رغم الصعوبته
يتم صياغته في واشنطن الامر في المقام
الاول يعود الى الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
ليتعلموا كيف يعيشوا مع بعض ما رايك دكتور
صالح النعامي بهذه الفكره انه ان الامر
يعود الى الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
للتعلم
بكيفيه العيش مع بعضهم
في الحقيقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وكل الادارات السابقه هي تلعب دور رئيس
وحاسم في تشجيع اسرائيل على المضيف هذه
الجرائم وتلك المجازر يعني عندما تقول انه
ضايفك من واشنطن بانه على الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين ان يتعلموا كيفيه التعايش
مع بعض وهي التي تقدم الدعم لاسرائيل
الاسبوع الماضي كان هناك مشروع قرار في
مجلس الامن
لتنديد
بقرار اسرائيل بناء الاف المستوطنات جاءت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبعثت ايضا مديرين المخابرات من الاردن
ومصر الضغط على السلطه الفلسطينيه لتراجع
عن هذا عن تقديم مشروع القرار
بمقابل لاحظي ليس فقط تراجع عن القرار
الذي اتخذ لبناء 9000 وحده سكنيه بل
بالالتزام بعدم الاصدار قرار
ببناء وحدات اخرى اسرائيل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي تواصل دعم اسرائيل
العسكريا وسياسيا وتمنع اي اي محاوله
لادانتها في المحافل الدوليه هي شريك اساس
ومهم في الجرائم التي ترتكبها اسرائيل
لانه بدون الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اسرائيل ليس بوسعها ان تواصل هذا النمط من
هذا السلوك الاجرامي دعنا ناخذ هذه الفكره
هذه هي النظره الفلسطينيه للدور الامريكي
الدعم اللامحدود وغير المشروط لاسرائيل من
جانب الولايات المتحده مهما فعلت هل
سيختلف هذا الامر باعتقادك
تماما افهم هذه العواطف المشاعر
الولات المتحده
تدعم اسرائيل لكنها حاولت في الماضي وبقوه
حاولت مساعده الفلسطينيين لكي يفهموا ما
يحتاجون لعمله لتحقيق حل الدوله انا كنت
في كامب ديفيد في العام 2000 عندما اعطى
الرئيس كلينتي الياسر عرفات هو رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل ما اعتبره افضل عرض للسلام واقامه
دوله فلسطين لكن الجانب الفلسطيني رفض ذلك
ولم نقترب من ذلك الاتفاق ابدا منذ ذلك
اليوم انا افهم ان
[موسيقى]
ايماءات اتجاه الولايات المتحده مهمه
لكنها لن تعوض التفاوض المباشر بين
الاسرائيلين الفلسطينيين وفي راي
الفكره الاساسيه
ان من انقلب على كل نتائج المفاوضات هي هو
الطرف الاسرائيلي اشكرك جزيل الشكر سنتوقف
هنا من واشنطن المتحدث السابق باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه وضيفنا من غزه الدكتور
صالح النعامي الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه شكرا لكما
طلب المندوب الفلسطيني لدى الامم المتحده
رياض منصور الامم المتحده بتنفيذ كافه
القرارات التي اعتمدتها سابقا بشان توفير
حمايه للمدنيين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله وقال منصور في تصريح للجزيره ان
التحركات الفلسطينيه والعربيه التي بدات
في المنظمه تهدف الى توفير هذه الحمايه
واداله ما وصفه بالمجزره الاسرائيليه في
نابلس
نحن في بدايه التحرك حول هذه المجزره التي
توقعت وتفاصيلها وان يكون كافه اعضاء مجلس
الامن والامين العام والامم المتحده
واللجان والكتل السياسيه المختلفه ان توضع
بالصوره ونطالب من المجتمع الدولي ان ينفذ
ويطبق قراراته في هذا الشان وان ينفذ
ويطبق موقفه الامين العام الذي جاء في
تقريره بشان
توسيع
المكنزمات الموجوده على الارض المتوفره
لديه بشان الحمايه
اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
عن قلقه العميق لسقوط قتل وجرح في نابلس
خلال العمليه الامنيه الاسرائيليه وعرب
غوتييرش عن قلقه ازاء التدابير العقابيه
التي اتخذتها اسرائيل ضد السلطه
الفلسطينيه وقال ان الحاله في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله وصلت الى اعلى مستوى
من التوتر منذ سنوات
نلتقي والحاله في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله اكثر قابليه للاشتعال منذ سنوات
كانت هناك تطورات مقلقه بشده اسفرت عمليه
شنتها القوات الاسرائيليه وما عقب ذلك من
اشتباك في نابلس عن مقتل عشره فلسطينيين
واصابه اكثر من ثمانين تستمر دورات العنف
المميته في التسارع والتوترات مرتفعه
للغايه ولا تزال عمليه السلام متوقفه هذا
الوضع يثير عدم الاستقرار في جميع انحاء
المنطقه وخارجها
[موسيقى]
قال رضا بالحاج القيادي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه المعارضه في تونس ان قوات امنيه
اقتحمت منزل عصام الشاب الامين العام
للحزب الجمهوري المعارض واعتقلته وقال
نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه الخلاص وشقيق عصام
الشاب ان مجموعه من عشرين عنصرا امنيا
اعترضوا شقيقه عصام عندما كان برفقه زوجته
في الشارع واعتقنوه بعد تفتيش منزله ودانت
حركه النهضه اعتقال الشاب واعتبرته اعتداء
جديدا على احد رموز المعارضه لما وصفته
بالانقلاب الغاشم ياتي اعتقال الشاب ضمن
سلسله اعتقالات تشنها السلطات التونسيه
على معارضين لاجراءات الرئيس قيس سعيد
شملت سياسيين واعلاميين ورجال اعمال وقضاه
ومحامين ويعد الشاب بارفع سياسيا من حيث
الصفه الحزبيه يعتقل حتى الان كما افادت
مصادر الحقوقيه تونسيه باعتقال الرياضيه
في جبهه الخلاص المعارضه شيماء عيسى
وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان هناك
حملات وصفها بالمسعوره من اشخاص قال انهم
ماجورون من الخارج لضرب الدوله التونسيه
على حد تعبيره اضاف سعيد انه يخوض حربه
تحرير وطني دعيا القضاء الى القيام بدوره
وتطبيق القانون على الجميع
ويحبوا يرجعوا للشعب كما العدويه بالضبط
اللي انتهت مده صلاحيتها ولا بعض الاغذيه
لدى انتهت مده السلوقيتها ومن ايضا مده
سلوحيتهم ولذلك تراهم
وثم
الحملات المسعوره امتاع الناس الماجورين
وعملاء
للخارج ولجهاد المشبوهه لضرب الدوله
التونسيه
وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه يتابع بقلق
التطورات الاخيره في تونس التي اعتبرها
جاره قريبه جدا تربطه معها شراكه عميقه
واستراتيجيه اضاف في بيان ان تونس تمر
بلحظه حساسه ويامل الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
تتمكن السلطات التونسيه من العثور على
الحلول المناسبه للعديد من التحديات
الحاليه والمستقبليه التي تواجهها البلاد
معنى من تونس احمد الهمامي المتحدث باسم
تحالف احرار مرحبا بك سيد احمد الهمام من
يقصد الرئيس عندما يتحدث عن العملاء
والناس الماجورين وانه يقوم بحرب تحرير
وطني ما المقصود بكل ذلك
شكرا لكم تحياتي لكل المتابعينكم في كامل
جميع الوطن العربي الرئيس قيس سعيد عندما
يتحدث عن العملاء ويتحدثوا على الخونه
ويتحدث على من وضعوا ذمتهم على قوى
الاجنبيه هذا يتحدث على من كانوا سببا في
الخراب في عشريه سوداء الرئيس قيس سعيد
الان في حرب تحرير وطني وليس هو وحده لانه
هو مصدر يعني الاساسي والناس تنظر الى
الرئيس سعيد
احمد يعني عندما نتحدث عن الخراب في
العشريه السوداء هذه تهمه فضفاضه جدا قد
يعني يتفاوت كثيرا تتفاوت كثيرا التفسيرات
بشانها ما المقصود تحديدا من وراء كلام
الرئيس سعيد والذي يتزامن مع كل هذه
الملاحقات القضائيه والتوقيفات بحق
المعارضين
طبعا شكرا لك وسؤالك ممتاز صديقتي العزيزه
الرئيس قيس سعيد يتحدث على من تتعلق بهم
شبهات امنيه والقضاء تم استدعاء هؤلاء سوى
من وكيل الجمهوريه او من قاضي تحقيق
استدعاهم للمثول امامله والقانون يسمح
بذلك لان تونس دوله القانون والمؤسسات وان
كانوا ابرياء سوف يبرئهم القانون لان تونس
هي بالقانون اليوم توقف او تم ايقافه من
ايام هو يعني
ذات محل شبهه قويه قاضي تحقيق لم يصدر في
حقهم بطاقات ايداع بالسجن لان قاضي
التحقيق لا يصدر بطاقات اذاعه السجن جوزيف
بل اذا توفرت معلومات كافيه وتوفرت ابحاث
كافيه عند الباحث في البدايه يعني هناك
شبهه كبيره يعني سيد احمد ابقى معي سن
معنا في هذا الحوار السيد المولد الفاهم
عضو المكتب التنفيذي للحزب الجمهوري
والحزب الجمهوري اليوم جرى توقيفه رئيسها
السيد عصام الشابي سيد المولد الفاهم هل
فهمتم اسباب هذا التوقيت وبالطريقه التي
جرى بها
لا يمكن
ان نقبلها
الان هناك
مطاردات الى
وهذا يعني حرمان
جزء هام من الشعب التونسي من التعب انا
ارادته
وعلى وهذه الديمقراطيه وهي ركن من اركان
اساسي
لنظام جمهوري
هاته الاساليب وناخذ هذه المطارده ونلفظ
هذا الارهاب هذا هو الارهاب بعينه
لماذا تعتبرونه ارهابا ضيفنا السيد احمد
الهمامي يقول هذه ملاحقات قضائيه القضاء
مستقل ينظر في اتهامات يبرا من يبرئ ويتم
توقيف او ملاحقه من هم على يعني من تثبت
التهم بحقهم
منزله فرقه مقاومه الارهاب
اين يتمثل لها ممارسه
الاخلمين العام
او التهديد
الحزب الجمهوري
عام
الحزب الجمهوري معناها
يعني هم مناضلين منذ عشرات
سنوات والحزب الجمهوري السليل التجمع
الاشتراكي التقدمي والحزب الديمقراطي
التقدمي ومناظنيه وقياداته
الساحه التونسيه والسلطه التونسيه تعرف
جيدا
هؤلاء
المناضلون لا يمكن اي اتحاد من الاحوال
نقبل
شكرا لك على المولد الفاهم عضو المكتبه
التنفيذي للحزب الجمهوري ضيفنا من تونس
وشكرا للسيد احمد الهمامي المتحدث باسمي
تحالف احرار ايضا من تونس شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي قام بعمل مهم لفتره طويله من
الزمن وانه من المهم ان يبقى الحلف متحدا
للتصدي لاي عدوان قادم واشار بايدن في
كلمه له خلال اجتماع لقاده الدول الاعضاء
في النيت والشرقيه اوروبا بالعاصمه
البولنديه وارسو اشار الى زياده المساعدات
لاوكرانيا للدفاع عن سيادتها من جهه قال
الامين العام
ان الحلفه لن يسمح لروسيا بالانتصار
وسيدافع عن كل شبر من اراضي دول الاعضاء
اضاف الصوت ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ليس مستعدا للسلم وان على الناتو
تعزيز دعمه لاوكرانيا لتحقيق نصرها حسب
تعبيره
معنى من موسكو اندريه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الروسي ومن بريكسيل معنا فابريس
بوتيه مدير تخطيطي السياسات السابق في
النيتو مرحبا بكما سيد
كيف نظرت روسيا اليوم
لهذا الاجتماع اجتماع تسعه في بوخارست
هو الاجتماعي يشكل
لم يكن هناك شيء جديد مثل الاجتماع بسبب
واضح تماما
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه تشكل تهديدا
بنسبه اليوروسيا وما اهم بكثير ما سمعنا
في السابق وهذه المره بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تسعى لفرد الهزيمه
الاستراتيجيه على روسيا في اوكرانيا اي
نحن نتحدث عن
يعني
العمليه العسكريه الوجوديه بالنسبه لموسكو
فلذلك نحن نقف امام خيارين اما انتصار في
هذه المعركه
فبالتالي بالنتيجه تخفيض او انتهاء الحين
من الامريكيه في الكره الارضيه او فاشل
روسيا كدوله حتى ربما تفكك
من هذا التمتين لحلف الناتو
والوحده التي ان عمليا ما يحصل هو عكس ما
تقول
انا اعتقد ان الوحده
المستوى غير الدقيق في هذا المجال بسبب ان
هناك من الامريكيه في الناتو الاخرى لا
توجد لديهم اي فرصه لقرار سيادي فلذلك
امريكا تدير الامور في الناتو في في
اوكرانيا فلذلك طبعا نحن نتحدث من جيد
نقول ذلك نحن نتحدث عن مواجهه الشامله بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وحلفائها
لذلك
تتحول الامور الى مواجهه شامله مع
الولايات المتحده من وجهه نظر روسيا كيف
سيتعامل الغرب وحلف الناتو مع ذلك
اعتقد
اتحدى
ما جاء في هذه الفرضيه بانها مواجهه شامله
نعم
روسيا شعرت بانها مهدده لكن ليس من النيتو
لكن شعرت التهديد من حقيقه ان اوكرانيا
بلد حر وديمقراطي وهذا ما دفع بنظام بوتين
الى هذا العمل العدواني ضد اوكرانيا
وردت على ذلك اوكرانيا طبعا
قد مارست حقها الطبيعي في الدفاع عن نفسه
وفقا للماده الحاده والخمسين من ميثاق
الامم المتحده ووفقا لهذه الماده ايضا
هناك مجموعه من الدول تساعد اوكرانيا في
دفاع عن نفسه بعكس ما تقوله انت موسكو
تقول انها شعرت بالتهديد لانه كان هناك
نيه لتوسيع النيتو الى اوكرانيا وهو ما
ترفضه وبالتالي الحديث عن تمتين الناتو
وتمتين هذه الجبهه الشرقيه الا يخشى ان
ايضا ياتي بنتيجه معاكسه وتوسيع المواجهه
ربما
اعتقد ان ما هو مثير للاهتمام ان نرى بان
التوسع الذات شرقا هو الذي تسبب
بعنوان روسيا حسب هذه الفرضيه
طبعا
فنلندا والسويد ارادته وطالبتاه الانضمام
من اكثر من عام لكنهما حتى اللحظه ليس
مستعدتين جاهزتين بعد اذن هذا رغم انها
ضرووريته لفنلندا والسويد نرى ان حقيقه
الظروف هي التي تخلق الظروف المواسعه على
الارض لجعل بلدان مثل فنلندا
والسويد تسعى للتوسع وتنضم الى ان ربما
مزيد من البلدان
ستنضم ست بالانضمام لان روسيا هي التي
تصنع الظروف التي تؤدي الى ذلك ما الذي
سيتغير في العام مع دخول هذه الحرب عامها
الثاني كيف
تتعامل موسكو الان ميدانيا وسياسيا مع ما
يحصل
انا تقدر نحن دخلنا في معارك
طويله الامد يعني العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه ستستمر لا مجال هناك لتراجع كل
الاحاديث عن امكانيه التواصل الى التفاهم
مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومع
اوكرانيا كما نحن مبني على تصريحات لكل من
هي احتمالات ضعيفه جدا او حتى لا توجد
هناك اي امكانيات بشكل عام يعني من جديد
اقول امريكا تسعى لفرد الهزيمه
الاستراتيجيه على روسيا وبالمناسبه
المساله انضمام الحلفانات ومسجل في
الدستور الاوكراني اوكرانيا رفضت تنفيذ
الاتفاقيات حتى ميركل وغيرها من
ثم نرمنديه قال بانهم لم يسعوا لتنصيدا
الاتفاقيات فلذلك بالاساس ما شاهدناه
بالسياسه العضوانيه ضد روسيا لبدء هذه
العمليه ايضا
الصعيد الغربي ما الذي سيتغير يعني هناك
المزيد من الالتزام بدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
واقتصاديا ولكن كل هذا الدعم الكبير الذي
قدم حتى الان لم يمكن اوكرانيا بعد من وقف
هذه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
هل انتم محقون في ذلك لانه بيت القصيد هنا
ان روسيا
وبوتين شخصيا عليهم ان يدركوا انهم
ارتكبوا خطا استراتيجيا في مهاجمه
اوكرانيا ذلك البلد الحر الديمقراطي
ويبدو واضحا ان بوتين مستعد للتضحيه
بحياتي عشرات الالاف من حياه الشباب
الروسي فقط ليحقق او يطبق
استراتيجيه مصيرها الفشل اعتقد اننا
بالنسبه لاستشراف
المستقبل سنرى روسيا بلد يتراوح ما بين
ايران وكوريا الشماليه بلد معزول يعاني من
ضائقه اقتصاديه شكرا
حتى حتى الصين موقفها لم يكن لصالحهم
وربما لا يرون في روسيا سوى ملحق
لسياستها الخارجيه هذا ما فعله بوتين بسبب
شكرا
لسيده الكاتب والمحلل السياسي الروسي
ضيفنا من موسكو
بعد يوم واحد من زياره الرئيس بايدن الى
اوكرانيا حل كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين
في روسيا حيث التقى الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بوتين وصف العلاقات مع
الصين بانها في تطور مستمر وانها وصلت الى
افاق جديده يحدث هذا في وقت تتحدث وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه عن مبادره صينيه ودور
فعال لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه
في ظل ضغط دولي تواجهه روسيا جراء حربها
على اوكرانيا وما اعقبها من عقوبات غربيه
تبدو موسكو متحمسه لتعزيز علاقتها مع
بيجين علاقه يقول الرئيس الروسي لدى
استقباله كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين انها
بلغت افاقا جديده اما الخارجيه الروسيه
موقف الصين من الحرب بالمتوازن مع التاكيد
على تطابق رؤيتي الدولتين الى حد كبير
ورحبت المتحدثه باسمها بمبادره الصين للعب
دور فعال في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه مبادره
لم تتضح بعد ملامحها ولا الموقف الاوكراني
منها لكن تنظر اليها بعين الربا بحكم
التقارب الصيني الروسي تقارب في علاقات
كانت محكومه بتنافس على النفوذ في وسط
اسيا وتعامل شبه ندي حولته التغيرات
الدوليه الى تحالف موضوعي يجادل كثيرون
انه لحظي لا يجمع بين الصين وروسيا تحالف
رسمي لكن العلاقات بدات تتقوى تدريجيا
خلال السنوات الماضيه ورفعت الحرب على
اوكرانيا من ايقاع نموها وتوسع التعاون
ليشمل المجالات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه
والسياسيه لكن ميزان العلاقات مختل بشكل
كبير ومتزايد لصالح بيجين سياسيا لم تصف
الصين الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا بالغزو
ولم تصوت ضد روسيا في اي من قرارات مجلس
الامن التي تناولت الحرب وكاله بلومبر سبق
ونشرت ان الصين طلبت من روسيا تاجيل بدء
حربها على اوكرانيا الى حين انتهاء
اولمبياد بيجين الشتويه عام 2022 والتي
انتهت في العشرين من فبراير وهو ما يبدو
ان روسيا استجابت له حيث اعلنت بدا
عمليتها العسكريه في الرابع والعشرين من
الشهر نفسه اي بعد اربعه ايام من نهايه
الدوره الشتويه للالعاب
مسؤولون رؤوس تحدثوا عن ان تاجيل العمليه
العسكريه سمح لاوكرانيا بالاستعداد اكثر
للحرب وسهل وصول معدات عسكريه غربيه ما
عقد من حسابات الحرب من بدايتها بالنسبه
الى الروس اقتصاديا لا يتجاوز حجم
الاقتصاد الروسي عشر الاقتصاد الصيني
ويقول خبراء ان اعتماد موسكو على بيجين
سياسيا واقتصاديا يعني امكانيه منها بشكل
لم يكن ممكنا في السابق خصوصا في ملف
الامدادات الطاقيه التي تحتاج اليها الصين
وملف التنازع على النفوذ في منطقه اسيا
الوسطى حيث تتعارض رؤيه الدولتين للمنطقه
ما يعني سياده رؤيه الصين الحزام والطريق
على حساب روسيا ومشروعها في منطقه تعتبرها
مجالها الحيوي كما تشكل العلاقات مع الهند
نقطه خلاف اخرى حيث ترى فيها الصين اكبر
منافس اقليمي لها وتحاول تحجيم نفوذها
فيما تصير موسكو على الحفاظ على شراكتها
مع دلهي التي تعتبرها من اكبر شركائها
التجاريين
نائب رئيس البرلمان الاوكراني ان الرئيس
زيلينسكي طرح خطه للسلام خلال لقاءات قمه
العشرين واكد كورنيكو في مقابله خاصه مع
الجزيره ترحيب اوكرانيا بجهود احلال
السلام لكنه اشترط خضوع المبادرات للشروط
التي طرحها الرئيس الاوكراني
الرئيسكي دعا الى خطته لتحقيق السلام خلال
لقاءاته في قمه العشرين ستناقش هذه الخطه
بشكل موسع في الايام المقبله مع الامم
المتحده وسنوصلها لجميع المنتديات الدوليه
علينا ان نقوم بخطوات مثل تحديد التهديدات
النوويه مثلا وقضايا الامن والغذاء ويجب
ان تحل هذه المسائل باخراج القوات الروسيه
من جميع اراضينا ونرحب بجهود الشركاء
لاحلال السلم لكن على اساس الشروط التي
طرحها الرئيس زيلينسكي
ومع اكمال الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
عامها الاول وجد الاتحاد الاوروبي نفسه
امام مصاعب عده في قطاع الطاقه من ابرزها
ايجاد بدائل للاستغناء السريع عن مصادر
الطاقه الروسيه ولقى هذا التوجه اعتراض
اطراف اوروبيه مما حال دون التوصل لموقف
موحد
عهد جديد لطاقه لا تنتهي كلمات وصفت اطلاق
هذه المحطه شمال بلجيكا سبعينيات القرن
الماضي اليوم ياتي هذا المفاعل النووي
كبديل في واجهه ازمه الطاقه الاوروبيه مع
روسيا
ينتج الاتحاد الاوروبي حاليا اقل من نصف
احتياجاته من خلال الطاقه النوويه والغاز
الطبيعي والفحم والطاقه المائيه والرياح
والطاقه الشمسيه
الاستخدام الجيد والمعتدل للموارد التي
لدينا بالاضافه الى المصادر البديله مثل
طاقه الرياح والطاقه الشمسيه والمحطات
النوويه جعلتنا قادرين على مواجهه الازمه
كنا قبل الحرب نعتمد على شركائنا في
النرويج لاجل الغاز واليوم طورنا علاقاتنا
معهم وكذلك توسعنا في استخدام المصادر
البديله
وامام ازمه الطاقه الناجمه عن الحرب في
اوكرانيا لم يحقق الاتحاد الاوروبي اجماعا
في فرض عقوباته على روسيا اذ عارضها بعض
الاعضاء كالمجر وبلغاريا مما اعطاهما
استثناءات لكن الاتحاد مضى في التحرك بما
يعفيه من الاعتماد على روسيا
قمنا بزياده مستويات التخزين لدينا قبل
عام كان تخزين الغاز في جميع انحاء اوروبا
منخفضا جدا سيكون لدينا دائما بوليصه
التامين ضد اي تخفيضات في العرض وتمكنا من
استبدال جميع الشحنات الغاز التي قطعتها
روسيا واعتمدنا على واردات الغاز الطبيعي
المسال من شركاء مختلفين بعضهم في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا والولايات المتحده
فرض الاتحاد جمله من العقوبات على روسيا
منذ الصيف 2022 لاول مره شملت مصادر
الطاقه وقطاعه تكنولوجيا والاستثمار فيهما
هو اذا طريق سلكه الاتحاد الاوروبي في
اتجاه مستقبلي لا يعرف ماله بمازق الطاقه
تجد اوروبا نفسها بين مستقبل تسعى فيه
لاعتماد مصادر بديله وبينماض ترتبط فيه
بشريك تركته دون رجعه وبين هذا وذاك واقع
سياسي واقتصادي جديد يجعل من فتره ما بعد
الحرب ليس كما قبلها عبد الله الشامي
الجزيره
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي رفض بلاده لما وصفها بالضغوط
السياسيه التي تسعى الى اجبارها على تنفيذ
التزامات الالتزامات النوويه من طرف واحد
ونفى اسلامي ما وصفها بالاتهامات الباطله
لبلاده بشان كشف يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 84
وكانت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قد
قالت لاحد الماضي انها تناقش نتائج انشطه
التحقق الاخيره مع ايران بعد ان افادت
وكاله بلومبرج باكتشاف الوكاله ليورانيوم
مخصب بدرجه نقاء 84% وهو ما يقترب من درجه
صنع الاسلحه
تعاون ولوم تستقبل بهما طهران مفتشي
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذين
وصلوا الثلاثاء لبحث ملفات عالقه لا تكف
ايران عن تاكيد التعاون مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بموازاه رفض متجدد
لما تعتبره ضغوطا سياسيه او تنفيذا
للاتفاق النووي من طرف واحد الزياره
الحاليه لمفتشين الوكاله جاءت على وقع
اتهامات بشان اكتشاف نسب تخصيب عاليه
لليورانيوم سارع المسؤولون الايرانيون
بنفيها
من الوكاله موجودون في ايران وبداوا بضيوم
امس مناقشه الاتهامات الموجهه الينا بشان
كشف يورانيو مخصب بنسبه 84% وهذه
الاتهامات ناتجه عن تقارير خاطئه من احد
مفتشي الوكاله
يوم الاحد الماضي نشرت وكاله بلومبيرج
مذكره لدبلوماسيين افادت ان وكاله الطاقه
الذريه رصدت بايران يورانيوم مخصبا بنسبه
84% وهي نسبه تقارب المستوى المطلوب لصنع
سلاح نووي اثر ذلك رد مسؤولون في وكاله
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ان بلادهم ملتزمه
بنسبه 60% للتخصيب وان وجود يورانيوم مخصب
بنسب تتجاوز ذلك امر طبيعي اثناء عمليه
التخصيب وان العبره بالمنتج النهائي انتقد
الطهران ما تقول انه تسييس لعمل الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وابتعاد عن دورها
الفني تردد هذا اللوم في تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الايراني الذي ندد ايضا بمعتبرها
رسائل متناقضه من الطرف الامريكي بشان
العوده للاتفاق النووي
مستعدون لاتمام مباحثات فيينا لكننا نتلقى
رسائل متناقضه من الطرف الامريكي تكون اي
عبر القنوات الدبلوماسيه ومتنقطه عبر
تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين في الاعلام لوح
عبد اللهيان بما سماها الخطه باء اذا اتخذ
الطرف الامريكي وفق قوله منحا مختلفا
مؤكدا اللانيه لبلاده في امتلاك قنبله
نوويه منذ 2018 تتهم طهران الجانب
الامريكي باجهاض الاتفاق النووي حين
انسحبت منه اداره ترامب وهي تبدي طوال
الوقت ترحيبها بالعوده بشرط رفع العقوبات
والا يكون السير باتجاه اتفاق جديد غير ما
ابرم عام 2015 بينما يتهمها خصومها
بخروقات عديده للاتفاق الاصلي وبانشطه
عسكريه وسياسيه اقليميه غير مرحب بها
غربيا
[موسيقى]
قرار روسيا تعليق مشاركتها في معاهده نيو
ستارت التي تنص على خفض عدد الاسلحه
النوويه جدد المخاوف من وقوع كارثه نوويه
فهل شهد العالم ازمات كادت ان تتسبب في
هذه الكارثه في اكتوبر عام
1962 في ذروه الحرب البارده جرت مواجهه
دبلوماسيه استمرت 13 يوما بين ورشه وموسكو
بعد ان كشفت صور التقطتها طائره تجسس
امريكيه عن وجود منصات اطلاق صواريخ
في كوبا قادره على الوصول الى الاراضي
الامريكيه صحيح ان الازمه انتهت باتفاق
واعد وراء الكواليس لكن قبل ابرامه وضعت
القوات الاستراتيجيه في حاله تاهب قصوى
وهو المستوى الذي يسبق اندلاع الحرب
النوويه المباشره وحلقت مئات الذريه في
السماء وتم تجهيز صواريخ العابره للقارات
في ليل الخامس والعشرين الى 26 من سبتمبر
عام
1983 وفي فتره توتر شديد بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي والولايات المتحده قدر ضابط
سوفيتي استنادا الى اشارات انذار من اقمار
مراقبه صناعيه ان اراضي ما كان يعرف
بالاتحاد السوفيتي قد تتعرض لهجوم وشيك
بخمسه صواريخ امريكيه او سته اتضح لاحقا
ان الامر ليس اكثر من انذار خاطئ والحادث
بقي سرا مده عشر سنوات في مايو 2022 كاد
الصراع بين الهند وباكستان بشان اقليم
كشمير يدخل مرحله مواجهه جديده بعد هجوم
على البرلمان الهندي قالت نيودلهي ان
مسلحين قادمين من اسلام اباد ضالعون فيه
بعد تهديدات النوويه وتجارب صاروخ متبادله
تعهد الطرفان بخفض التصعيد تحت ضغط من
واشنطن نشير الى ان الولايات المتحده هي
الدوله الوحيده في العالم التي استخدمت
بالفعل السلاح النووي في عام
1945 ضد اليابان حيث ادى قصفها لهيروشيما
ومقتل 140 الف شخص ثم نجازاكي ومقتل 74
الف شخص بعد ذلك بثلاثه ايام ادى الى
استسلام اليابان وانتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه للمزيد حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من جنيف اندريه
كبير الباحثين في برنامج اسلحه الدمار
الشامل بمعهد الامم المتحده لابحاث نزع
السلاح سيد
اليوم روسيا اعلنت انها تلتزم بالحدود
المتفق عليها في اتفاقيه ستارت فيما يتعلق
بالرؤوس النوويه هل يعني
لذلك من مخاطر تعليق
مشاركه روسيا في هذه الاتفاقيه
طبعا تجميد المشاركه وتعليقها بالتاكيد
افضل من الانسحابي تماما لانه قرار سياسي
يمكن ان يعكس اذا ما وافقت الاطراف
المعنيه على العوده الى الاتفاق مره اخرى
لكن واضح ان الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل كما
يقال لان
معاهده ستارت تعتمد على جانبين وهو احترام
الحدود
وايضا التاكد من ذلك والتحقق منه عبر
عمليات التفتيش روسيا تقول هي ستحترم هذه
الحدود لكن سيكون الامر صعبا على الوقت
المتحده ان تتحقق من ذلك لهذا السبب على
المدينه المتوسط والبعيد
المدرسه طبعا يكونوا ضارا جدا بالمعاهده
وعندما نقول انه ضار جدا
بالدارور جدا بالمعاهده ما الذي على المحك
عمليا
اخر
معاهده استراتيجيه للحد من انتشار الاسلحه
بانولات المتحده
وروسيا هذا ما بقي من سياسه السيطره والحد
من التسلح والسباقه التسرع لاننا فقدنا
معاهدات اخرى تتعلق بالصواريخ بعيده المدى
العابره للقارات وغيرها طبعا هذا يجعل ان
هناك احتمال ان يكون هناك عوده الى سباق
تسلح لكن ما هو اسوء من ذلك هو ان كل
النولات المتحده وروسيا
لا تعتبران موضوع
الحد من سباق التصلح كجزء من العلاقه
بينهما لان العلاقه بينهم اصلا متاذمه وقد
يعتبران ان ب اي بلد ان يرتجل مواقفه هكذا
حسب الظروف لكن
هذه الامور تبقى محل قلق حقيقه لانه
بالنسبه
للبلدان الاخرى التي ستراقب عن كثب ما
تقوم به الصين ولا المتحده الصين طبعا من
جانبها
توسع من نطاق ترى هناك بلدان اخرى في
المنطقه واضح ان هذا التطور يقودنا باتجاه
تطورات اخطر حقيقه طيب في ظل هذه الصوره
من القادر على تامين بديل لجم اي سباق
تسلح محتمل يعني تنظيم لهذا الخلاف ولهذه
العلاقه
المتازمه بين مختلف الاطراف التي تمتلك
اسلحه نوويه
للاسف لا احد اتى عن البلدان النوويه
نفسها يستطيع ان يقرر الحد من
اسلحتها لا توجد قوه في العالم تستطيع عمل
ذلك راينا معاهدات من قبل لكن
البلدان طبعا هي هي التي تقرر في النهايه
الى اي مدى تولي اعتبار لهذه الامور طبعا
البلدان النوويه تعتبر امتلاكها للسلاح
النووي هو الضمان الاعلى والاكبر وهم طبعا
قصدي يقررون على وضع حد عليها لكن ليس
التخلص منها طبعا ابتداء في السبعينيات
المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي اعتبره بان وضع
بعض القيود والحدود لكنه فائده له لكن من
الصعب ان نرى كيف يمكن حل هذه المعضله
الباحثين في برنامج اسلحه الدمار الشامل
في معهد اللمم المتحده لابحاث نزع السلاح
ضيفنا من جنيف
[موسيقى]
تحذيرات من عواصف شتويه وثلجيه ورياح قويه
لاكثر من 65 مليون شخص في 29 ولايه
امريكيه ومناطق واسعه في غرب وشمال ووسط
البلاد وتاجيل او الغاء لاكثر من الف
وثلاثمائه رحله جويه خلال اليومين
الماضيين ليس ذلك فحسب فقد تسببت الرياح
القويه في انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن 163
الف منزل وشركه في كاليفورنيا وبينما
تترقب مناطق عده في الولايات المتحده
سقوطا قياسيا للثلوج اغلقت المدارس في
ولايات داكوتا
وحث مسؤول المرور في منشوتا
وساوث ونورث داكوتا سائقي السيارات على
القياده ببطء او تجنب استخدام السيارات
خلال اليومين المقبلين نتمنى السلامه
للجميع نواصل تغطيتنا الاخباريه
بعد موجز رياضيا مع لؤي محمود شكرا
لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء